Germanium is the first element in the periodic
table,
beginning at hydrogen, that’s named after
a country: it is
named after Germany. There are other elements
named after
France and Poland and America but we will
come to those
later.
One of the things about Germanium and what
really makes it
important in the periodic table is that this
is one of the
elements which was unknown when Mendeleev
constructed
the periodic table and he predicted its existence
and when it
was found it had many of the properties that
he had
predicted based on the change in properties
as you go down
and across the periodic table.
So this is a small sample of germanium, named
after
Germany, so you can see the wonderful shiny
surfaces.
Germanium is used quite widely as a so-called
semi-
conducting material. If you look at it in
visible light it looks
like a metal.
Germanium na, na, n-na na.
I have used germanium mirrors in some of my
experiments.
The lasers that I used when I was younger
had a germanium
mirror that let the light out at the front
of it and germanium
is used quite widely in electronics.
This is quite a nice piece of germanium. Unfortunately
I broke
it somewhat earlier in my career, but you
can see very nicely
how this material looks like a piece of metal
but on the other
hand if you shine infrared light through it,
it’s transparent so
the infrared light will through but visible
light doesn’t.